so it looks like John Vega may be done
with Star Wars so it reads here at this
point I'm cool with it I'm good at it I
think Finn is at a good confirmation
point where you can just enjoy him and
other things the games the animation but
I feel like episode 7 to episode 9 was
good for me now in some previous
interviews which were done quite some
time ago John bragger did go on to say
that he would be down to play
um Finnegan if the story it was right
and if JJ Abrams and Kathleen Kennedy
was enrolled but I guess since then he
has changed his opinion and he no longer
through likes he wants to be involved in
the movies which I guess is a fair point
because you can change your opinion now
kind of the opposite thing happened with
Oscar Isaac as originally when he was
asked if he would um come back to Star
Wars he said only if I would need a
second house and then in a previous
interview which I think was done a
couple weeks ago he said he would be
down to do Star Wars again if there was
a really good story so maybe he does
need the second house but I don't know
anyway let me know you guys thoughts in
the comment section below do you think
John Vega is actually done with Star
Wars or did shooting this still is a
possible chance that he could come back
let me know in the comment section below
and we haven't already please like And
subscribe to show your support thanks
for watching